التوقيت الصيفي والتوقيت الشتوي مصطلحان
كان من اكثر مصطلحات بحثا على الانترنت
بعد الجدل الكبير الذي اثاره تاجيل تغيير
التوقيت في لبنان فما هو التوقيت الصيفي
وما هو التوقيت الشتوي وما الفرق بينهما
التوقيت الصيفي هو تغيير التوقيت الرسمي
في كل بلاد لعده اشهر من كل سنه حيث تتم
فيه اعاده ضبط الساعات الرسميه في بدايه
الربيع لتقديم عقارب الساعه 60 دقيقه
ويكون عاده في شهر مارس وينتهي في شهر
اكتوبر اما التوقيت الشتوي فهو الرجوع
للتوقيت الاصلي ويتم ذلك مع بدايه فصل
الخريف وناتي هنا الى السؤال الاهم ما
الفائده من تغيير التوقيت الى الصيفي تخيل
معي انك تحصل على ساعه اضافيه في يومك من
ضوء النهار وهذه بالضبط الغايه من تغيير
التوقيت ساعه اضافيه من ضوء الشمس ما يقلل
الحاجه الى استهلاك الكهرباء والطاقه
وبالتالي توفير بعض المصاريف والتكاليف
الماديه توجد حول العالم 70 دوله تعتمد
هذا النظام وتغير توقيتها بشكل دوري كل
سنه الا ان دول الخليج والبلدان القريبه
من خط الاستواء لا يتغير توقيتها على مدار
السنه اما عن اول دول اعتمدت التوقيت
الصيفي فكانت المانيا وبريطانيا عام 1916
اثناء الحرب العالميه الاولى وذلك بسبب
حاجه السكان الماسه الى ضوء النهار من اجل
توفير الفحم